welcome everyone to classic middle class
session 20. and this time it's going to
be a bit more philosophical i think
although we're going to do a lot of uh
delving into music history to use
examples because what we want to talk
about here is it's a it's a topic we've
brought up before
who counts as an original or founding
member of a band and then we'll also
look at the question why do we care so
much about this why does it give
somebody a kind of cred to be part of
the the origin
of a band and as it turns out it's it's
a way more complicated issue than we
would at first think of and it it came
up
recently because rudy sarzo the great uh
bassist scott and i were just talking
about all the different bands that he's
played in um you know best known perhaps
for quiet riot but he was an integral
part of white snake
um blue oyster cult um we were naming
ozzy right that's right he played with
well early on with ozzy right yeah he
was he was one of those people who was
poached
uh by the aussie
organization let's call it yeah and so
um
rudy sarzo has rejoined quiet riot
uh so this is his third time being in
the band
and well actually fourth time if we if
we count it in in certain ways
and there have been a lot of interviews
with him about why are you rejoining
what's going on and he got asked a
question whether he considered himself
to be an original member
and we're going to look at some of the
things that he says and i think there's
actually a good case for calling him an
original member of the band i think some
of the things that he said are pretty on
point
i'm not sure where you're on that scott
or where anybody else is
because technically he's not
a original founding member of the first
quiet riot
but there's more to the picture and and
as we started talking about this
scott and i realized that this is way
more complicated than we originally
thought because there's all sorts of
conundrums that arise well what if a
band
breaks up and reforms
like quiet riot did or like the
scorpions did or as we're going to talk
about iron maiden did and judas priest
did who counts as an original
members so there's a lot of distinctions
to
explore um i think we'll start out by by
looking at the sarso situation as we're
going to call it first because it
provides such a great case study but
scott is there anything you wanted to
say before we jump into reading these
these excerpts
yeah i think
just one of the things that came up in
us talking about it was
um
there's
there's original in the sense that they
were in the band first but then you know
well wait a minute who is in the band
when the the band took off for their
first huge album is that something we
should consider yeah um or
you know we were talking about
um well he would take a band like the
cars elliot easton wasn't the original
guitar player of the cars but he was on
every record that they put out right so
um
you know i i i think
um
we have to consider you going back to
the bar band version of it where they
play covers right you know are you
which
and this is you know what you said it
became incredibly complicated because
you and i kept hitting back and forth
well wait a minute what's the criteria
it's not so simple i don't think so
hopefully we'll we'll get to address
these point by point we'll start with
rudy sarzo obviously you know something
that i haven't asked you about but now
it occurs to me i should to you know
exploit your background and talents
this question of originality
um is this more of a
a fan and like critic
kind of issue or do musicians care about
this a lot i mean would musicians care
like would would somebody like rudy
sarzo care if people weren't pestering
him with questions about this does it
matter from from like a musician's
perspective who the original members are
it depends on the situation because i
mean
we know that like when jakey lee joined
he just said the fans used to give him
the finger and
and you know we're talking about well
you know okay your choices ozzy stops
making music because randy's gone
um
you know i one time when i was 18 i
joined a band that was doing really well
in boston
and i replaced their original guitarist
who was a wildly different player than
me
and they wanted to start like this you
know new thing and they already had some
hits if we could call that but um
but then we became our our own thing was
i the original original no but i was on
a bunch of the
songs of that whole era that like you
know we kind of toured that stuff or
played that stuff so yeah i guess you
know someone like gene simmons well
actually he you know there's that big
debate where's ace freely where's peter
chris where's
um you know i you know i think it
depends on the situation you know i
think a a band or a group of musicians
will do what's best for the band then
you know if people can't like sticks is
a great example dennis dion can't get
along with
j.y and tommy
and um
and then we just hear the blame game
going back and forth i don't you know
because they're asked about it i think
you nailed it because people keep asking
dennis you ever going to go back dennis
would you go back dennis you know or you
know why aren't you getting back with
dennis or you know and you know
they're asked these questions
and i don't i don't know that's a
band of that level or maiden or whatever
the the fans will have their opinions i
guess
right yeah but what yeah i guess what
we're getting at here is
well
what you know if we really don't go from
a completely emotional you suck you're
not the original guy
you know uh we don't go for that knee
jerk emotional reaction what do we come
up with actually yeah
yeah
i mean that's an interesting topic the
resentment that people sometimes feel
when either a musician has died or a
musician has stepped away from
the band and they've been replaced
there's this
largely irrational demand that first of
all the past not have it you know
included this this terrible event right
everything should be going on as normal
but also
the expectation that the new person
should um
conform
to like they're you know they're
stepping into somebody's slot
not their own slot right so i mean the
jk lee um randy rhodes thing is a just a
perfect example
because two quite different kinds of
players right
and and they both put out really great
albums
um each of them got two albums with with
ozzy
but they're
very different sounds you know
yeah i mean um
we know that randy wrote a lot of that
stuff you know and it was apparent that
like like died of a madman he was
studying leo brower pieces because he
was starting to study classical and all
that stuff sounds it sounds like leo
brower pieces yeah the guitar parts um
and then jakey lee ended up coming out
saying you know i just want credit
because i wrote a lot of that stuff i
don't want the i don't need the money i
just want them to admit i wrote it a
perennial problem with the aussie
organization isn't it you know i i
actually so a good segue into the
interviews because one of the things
that i did find in interviews that was
kind of interesting speaking of
randy rhodes and what he contributed to
to ozzy's um uh blizzard of oz
originally and then just ozzy osbourne
is that he brought a bunch of quiet riot
early quite riot material
and since he thought the band was
essentially defunct he repurposed like
riffs
and fed them into some of the the aussie
songs so oh here's a good point from
from mark
uh an important point to consider is
financial there's a distinction between
the practical and legal origin of the
band yeah what does the contract say and
some of the people who weighed in about
that they're like listen i signed a
contract i'm a founding member rudy
sarzo is a good example of that
that doesn't necessarily touch upon the
authentic identity of the group and it's
often a sore point of contention for
band members and and fans yeah well
we'll we'll
the the contention there's some stuff
with the sarzo uh and whole quiet riot
thing as well so let's jump in so in
this blabbermouth interview
um earlier he zarzo said i'm returning
home going home to quiet riot at the
beginning of 2022 next year
and he says uh next year marks 58 years
of my journey with quiet riot because
that's when i met and started playing
with frankie benali another founding
member now here's where the the
important terminology came up another
founding member of the metal health
version of the band so sarzo was never
saying i was
there at the very inception i'm an
original founding member of quiet riot
the one that put out quiet riot one and
quiet riot two i'm a founding member of
the metal health version of the band
which you know for many of us was the
definitive quiet riot i didn't even know
that they had previous albums until
looking them up yeah yeah like a decade
ago
so um now why why did sarzo come back so
he says um
you know benali was dying of pancreatic
cancer
and sarzo got to spend a lot of time
with him
and uh benally's wife regina told sarso
frankie wanted me to come back to the
band he wanted if a founding
member there in the band
so this is sort of respecting you know
the last wishes of of somebody else
who's arguably a founding member of that
as well not the original
um drummer as we'll we'll talk about in
a bit
in the metal voice interview um
this is a video uh interview
sarzo was asked whether he considered
himself an almost original member after
replacing kelly garney
and so he said when you say almost
original member that would be like
saying frankie benali is not an original
member of quiet riot let me give you my
perception this is the way i look at it
there were two albums that were only
released in japan it was basically kind
of like releasing an independent ep
45 years ago when those records were
released the randy rhodes version of
quiet riot billboard magazine they
didn't even have a chart for that
nothing for imports or music that was
record released in japan
if you don't have a record deal in the
usa you got nothing you are not a
recording artist so technically
the clock starts with metal health
because that's when a band under the
name quiet riot got signed to
pasha columbia records i got a contract
i signed along with carlos and kevin and
frankie that disputes the fact that i am
not an original member so a lot of stuff
going on there right and this goes to
the thing that mark had raised about
well who actually signed the contract
um
now i think this is a really good
consideration
what do you think scott that
it's essentially like releasing an ep
not an lp
uh yeah well i remember that you know
back in the day you'd go to well
in boston there's tower records and they
had a small import section and you were
lucky if they could even tower records
as big as they were
if they had an import of somebody so i
mean
and i i i guess i still well you know
those those days are kind of gone like
that but it's not like um
that's true because things are just
released everywhere now right yeah so
back you know
back then i don't know i mean if it
wasn't if it wasn't released here you
didn't have a contract you didn't have
distribution here so he's right about
that um yeah
and i i you know mark brings up a great
point because
if he was if he penned the the american
not only is that the definitive album
but you know if if he penned
his signature with the band as the you
know the the first band releasing stuff
here
um
i remember when that came out that was a
new band to me when that album came out
you know right you're on the radio
yeah and um
i think i think he's
i think he's nailed it and you know i
that that whole quote about him saying
you know the clock starts here i agree
with him
you know he makes a good point
so
would you go as far as to say that i
mean he's using some pretty careful
language you know um founding member of
the mental health uh version of the band
um original member
at least in terms of
when things are released do you think
that
this
i mean
it would be confusing to say that he
or frankie benally are original members
per se
because then you'd say well what about
kelly garney
what about
randy rhodes what about what about these
other people who are not in the band by
the time that mental health is
configured
well i remember you know going back to
the time
maybe it was just from circus or or
whatever magazine yeah
i you know it was i even though it's
like hey do you know that randy rhodes
was actually in quiet riot
we thought that was a fun fact but we
didn't consider you know you know like
we see yeah yeah cars you know and quiet
riot it was kind of like even i could go
to my you know when that album came out
even reading all this stuff in the
magazines that was a fun fact but i i
said well you know
this is kind of a new band that he must
have been in early when they weren't
doing anything even at the time with
that information i didn't say oh so
randy's an original founding member no
he was like
the aussie guitarist even yeah i think
although he was an original founding
member although he was originally yeah
but like you know he moved away from the
band to join ozzie and yeah then
why wasn't he on mental health we knew
carlos is the guitarist um
yeah that's that that's an interesting
way to put it so here here's another
thing from uh the metal edge interview
um he said i don't know if people know
this but during the last break that
randy and i had from ozzy we were
hanging out with kevin dubrow as we
always did when he came back to la and
he said listen do you guys mind
if at some point i renamed dubrow as
quiet riot now the backstory to that was
there was a quiet riot right they
released quiet right one quiet riot two
toured a lot in the la scene were kind
of rivals to van halen
and then randy rhodes leaves um uh rudy
sarzo was the replacement for kelly
garney where you know there were
incredible personality conflicts between
him and kevin dubrow to the point where
kelly garney
actually had a loaded handgun and was
gonna kill kevin dubrow so band problems
so you know sarso joins and then uh
randy rhodes gets poached essentially by
ozzy and sarzo follows him and then the
band breaks up and
kevin dubrow is the band leader so he's
running this thing as dubrow so then
he's asking them do you mind if i
rename it quiet riot and so sarzo says
of course randy said yes gave him his
blessing so did i it was kind of in the
works about a new version of quiet riot
even when randy was still with us so he
is a second part of the
the story
um and there's some important
considerations i think we should you
know bring up scott mentioned already
that you know this is as far as we knew
us dumb metal had kids in the 80s
this was the quiet riot
and sarzo himself appeared in the music
videos
um that was massive in the early 80s
he toured with the band until 1985.
metal health was the first heavy metal
album to reach number one in the
billboard top 200 albums chart so that
really was a massive impact
and right now you can say that sarzo is
the only classic member of quiet riot's
current lineup
i mean it would be possible perhaps
um for like carlos cavazzo to come back
if the the current guitarist wants to go
away but there you know quiet riot is a
band
this came out in the interviews too that
was marked by incredible personality
conflicts
um
you know dubrow and garnie couldn't get
along
um apparently uh carlos cavazzo and
frankie benally didn't get along
um
kevin dubrow also had problems with rudy
sarzo
it's kind of hard to hold a uh super
group together when people can't get
along with each other
but um i mean you could
possibly potentially see
a reunited quiet riot with two of those
let's call it mental health founding
members
you know
um
yeah
you know in this case um
yeah i don't you know i i guess part of
the test here is you know just to bring
up again when we were like dumb kids in
the 80s like
that mental health
album that was the band right what
happened before was
you know touring local clubs or being a
regional band
you know um
yeah that and that's it they were in la
band you know right they were not going
out on massive worldwide tours or
anything like that as as you know the
the configuration that was doing the
worldwide tours was kevin dubrow
um uh carlos cavazzo uh frankie benally
and and rudy sarzo which is curious
because here here's an interesting point
that i'm thinking of if the first two
albums were available in japan i wonder
if you could buy those records at the
merch booth at like the whiskey when
they played or
at the mint you know it's like i wonder
if they had those they were
because i know in the 80s you weren't
allowed to sell your album at the merch
booth because the record companies
wouldn't let you oh
well how would they get their hands on
it though but that's what i mean you
mean the fans i mean so they're playing
material for the albums that the fans
can't get well how would how would even
the band get the albums from japan over
to la and then be able to sell them at
the merch booth you know
well you know
you know i'd have to know i'd have to
know like what deal they signed because
that would be a little weird that you're
playing clubs but you can't
you know if as a fan say you loved the
first one they said you wanted that
album and you can't go to the record
store and buy it
and you know
this is something that we haven't looked
into at all but i'm i'm willing to bet
there were probably a lot of bootlegs of
quiet of course there you know
but you know it goes to say like they
were
i guess
because
we don't i mean i didn't know anybody
with a copy of those
and um yeah i guess it's it's safe to
say that they were a local band that
didn't have pro even even have product
to sell at their shows
not that they didn't make it
but
before we talk a little bit about now
getting into the more philosophical
stuff i do want to say that that rudy
sarzo on on twitter actually weighed in
on this several times
and uh retweeted um something that i had
to say and then on his retweet said out
of respect to the randy rhodes version
of the band
which i was the second bassist of um
kevin frankie carlos and i regarded ours
regarded us as the mental health version
of quiet riot so you know reiterating
his his standard line which i think is
is quite right and i think at least in
that respect he's completely correct you
know
um
there is a mental health version that is
the definitive version of the band for
all intents and purposes
and
they're founding members you know
so let's let's talk about these terms
right we've got
a couple of them floating out there
we've got original and that seems to
have a couple different
meanings founding overlaps with original
but
might have a little bit of a
more narrow
meaning
then there's this member of classic
lineup that you see used a lot
and i think that's you know much more
important these days when there's you
know decades sometimes intervening
could talk about essential member
somebody being you know not an original
member but being an essential member of
the band and so we're going to get it
how can how can a human being be
essential to
a band we'll have to get into that a
little bit yeah
i think there's good reason to use that
that terminology and there's other words
floating around out there too right
i mean referencing the metal health
version that's sort of like saying
classic lineup
yeah
actually yeah
they do overlap but um essential that
needs to be on there because
if we're talking about the person that
writes the riffs or the the songs
yeah
you know we would say
um
forget the fact that he's a band leader
but steve harris
for so many ways he's an essential
member
you know his sound you know his bass
playing and he contributes most of the
classic writing you take him out of the
band i don't know if i want to buy that
album
yeah i and i i kind of think band leader
in the sense of like a steve harris or a
lemmy or
um i mean who else comes to my mick box
for um uriah heap
um
that's sort of like original member
squared you know
uh it is because they have so much
agency
right in what the band looks like
um
and sounds like i guess you could say
well that it's a big thing the
individual sound um
the the individual like you know um as
far as the contribution to the the sound
of the band you replace this person the
whole sentiment's gonna change music
yeah well and especially if that
person's also involved in production
yep you know so
like steve harris coming in and saying
that doesn't sound right in in the
production area he's going to have a
hell of a lot more weight than say nico
mcdane brain coming in and saying yeah i
don't like those drums there you know
well you know and i always go back to
the kansas you know the band kansas um
okay richard williams is the only
original member like everybody else is
retired or passed away and um
you know so he's got this whole band and
they're putting out a new kansas album
they always ask well you didn't even you
weren't even a writer in the band
and you know and so how is this a kansas
album if you're the only member and
you're not one of the writers he said
well i've been in kansas for 50 years or
whatever i think i know what a kansas
song sounds like
i mean that's that's that's nice to say
but you know you don't you haven't
written one you know yeah
um he wasn't i mean with all respect to
him because he's he is
you know he's an important member of
kansas but i don't know if i i think you
know
i didn't buy that album right i didn't
buy the one that he i mean he's out
promoting it right so um
this is interesting for mark i'm not
sure how to better phrase this but the
question to ask is which member
holds the vision of what the band is
together i actually like that the vision
of what the band is i mean scott and i
in the past have talked about
ethos um a band having a particular
ethos but but i think
that word vision or
there might be some other closely
connected words that that fit that as
well you know
where you could you could say this this
is what
so think about early iron maiden right
the eddie is involved in it that's part
of the vision
songs about um
uh
culture references war history
um
you know that's part of the vision the
two guitars playing off of each other
sonically as part of the vision but it's
also something out on the stage those
two guys like standing next to each
other and playing right that's part of
the visuals yeah
so yeah
uh yeah i mean
and that could change but i think as
long as it changes
within the artist's view so it's like
you know like i guess when yeah when our
maiden went into somewhere in time or
judas priest turbo right
well in turbo i mean we had a shock but
it was the it was the real people saying
we're gonna try this out yeah but you
know i don't i don't know if we would
have given it a pass if it was like not
rob rob halford and kk if they were
replaced and then all of a sudden the
band had a a tur an album like turbo put
out turbo i don't know if we would
we would be angry rather than
disappointed
[Music]
like well there were plenty of there
were people who were angry at turbo when
it came out and somewhere in time you
know
what's with all this synthesizer stuff
you know the music has become soulless
people were saying i remember and you
know that was like uh we have new
technology let's you know let's use it
which
which follows you know it around but you
know it came out in the wash because
um they didn't continue on that path
i mean
some of the stuff on ram it down had
that sound but that's because they
recorded it back in the turbo
like the title track ram it down or not
ram it down but um blood red skies you
know very much a synth driven song
right
so yeah
but you know very heavy i mean it rivals
the sentinel i would say for heaviness
um
i don't think it gets played that often
and get concert setless but
i think i think i've seen it once
really yeah i think so
but let's let's go back to the
philosophy stuff so original member
right if we want to be
strict literal perhaps even pedantic
about this then there's only one way to
talk about it you're you're only an
original member if you were there at the
inception of the band as a
unit and and maybe it has to be the band
that's named that band you know
so like um
don dawkin
his band had a different name uh before
uh it switched to dawkin
maybe you only include the people from
the dock and you know name era onward
and
the odds are like well like scott was
saying that whatever band you're talking
about was probably just a local band at
that time so um you know if we're
talking about van halen it's uh la if
we're talking about styx chicago right
it took him a while to break out of that
that
environment and for some of the bands
this isn't really much of an issue
because they've had such continuity so
you know who are the founding members of
kiss
we all know right
um gene simmons
paul stanley ace really and uh
um i'm suddenly i'm seeing that the cat
and the kitty cat yeah clicking on his
name um
saying beth um yeah um now you got me
oh boy this is what what a confusion
right um but so
you could think about that or you could
think about like black sabbath who who
are the you know original members of
black sabbath
you know it's the the guys who are on
those first albums because the band
didn't change a lot over time
you could say that with motley crue
right they've they've had
a couple shifts right so they they
changed singers at one point i think it
was what john karabee
replaced vince neil
but now they're back together and it's
it's the original band right so that's
easy right
but
if we're thinking about quiet riot then
it's got to be randy rhodes kelly gardy
kevin dubrow and drew forsyth so it
wouldn't include carlos cavazzo or rudy
sarso or frankie benally the only
original member of the band who is still
there in the mental health heir was
kevin dubrow
deep purple is an interesting case in
point right because
so it was this guy rod evans singing um
who's definitely not ian gillen
um nick simper on the base instead of
roger glover and then you know the three
of richie blackmore john lord and ian
pace and so
ian gillen's not an original member
nor is roger glover by those
by that definition
yeah i mean but the i keep going to the
extreme case ringo stars not the
original beatles drummer though well
that if we applied this criteria you're
right he would not be the original
drummer motorhead's another great point
right we got lemmy and if you say well
who's who are the original members of
motorhead well you know lemmy fast eddie
and phil taylor no because the original
configuration
had larry wallace as the guitarist and
lucas fox on drums and then you know
lemmy shifted them out pretty quick
van halen
david lee roth would not be an original
member of the band michael anthony would
not be an original member
um at first eddie was actually singing
so
he's a pretty good singer and you know
and it's great you bring up van halen
because
michael anthony is an essential sound
not only his bass playing but his voice
so yeah yeah and it to the point where
we know that they were using tapes for
the backing vocals live when you know
wolfgang was playing bass and faking the
vocals because
that that backup sound was is is um
michael anthony it's like
yeah my michael anthony is sort of like
um juan crocier in that you don't have
the rat
vocal sound without two vocalists one of
whom is credited as the vocals which is
um
uh um
percy stephen percy right
um but steven percy's voice can't do the
rat sound without the high end same
thing with michael anthony it's the high
end that's being contributed
and he's not quite a lead vocalist but
he's definitely not a not a
backup vocalist
yeah i mean it's very recognizable like
you know the harmonies
you know like the the the chorus that's
like that's that's got the specific
sound
yeah
it's it's like um
uh
it's not metal but um
lindsey buckingham and stevie nicks when
they sang harmonies i mean a lot of
times they're on other people's records
because that's one sound you can't get
from
other singers so it's like um
just recognizable
you know lindsey buckingham yes he sings
lead but it's the two of them together
on the choruses that really make that
sound yeah so i mentioned dawkin right
don dawkins band originally included
juan crocier and bobby blotzer both of
whom are going to go over to rat yep and
greg leon so you know if we were to say
what's what's the classic dock and
lineup we would definitely say george
lynch jeff pills and mick brown but
none of them are original members in the
strict sense
another thing that's kind of interesting
girls school you know
massively influential new wave of
british heavy metal band
um it would include kim mcauliffe kelly
johnson and ed williams and denise
dufourt but not jackie chambers or tracy
lamb who were really essential to the
the band as well
uh metallica
metallica would not include kirk hammett
or cliff burton but would include
dave mustain
and you know it's so funny because we
heard that when megadeth came out we
heard about
or i heard about um well you know he's
he's the original guy from metallica and
they had this big beef but i didn't yeah
i only knew that from the interviews
they didn't have an album a metallica
album with dave mustain on it
well he was credited in writings uh
for some of the songs and kill them all
was he oh
but you'd have to like look at the
songwriting credits yeah i have to go
back and look yeah i mean it was it was
there was plenty of it in the the
magazines like circus and hit parader
because dave mustain was so incredibly
angry all the time
you know and and uh saying that you know
i mean his emphasis was to have a
heavier faster better band than
metallica right
which by the way it was a controversial
thing i would say that in the long run
he actually pulled that off i i think
that metallica and mega death are kind
of like toe to toe for those first three
albums
and then you know as metallica becomes
more poppy and and
i won't quite say cells out but you know
some people would uh megadeth just keeps
chugging ahead yeah
no i i agree with that i think a lot of
metalheads ended up you know say well
i mean you know metallica for people in
our
uh in our age range yeah the most part
people i talked to you know it was like
over with a black album it was like that
was it yeah yeah and it's not that they
came back either like
and well i mean if you think about so
there's a bit of a digression right the
trajectory from kill them all to master
of puppets really really solid stuff not
a bad song on the album
and then there's you know
the unfortunate death of cliff burton
the change to you know how the
songwriting is going and the mechanics
of the band they bring in jason neustadt
who they admit that they treat it as
basically like a hired hand yep and they
do the garage days re-revisited which is
good because it's you know metallica had
had been known for
doing um cool covers of other people's
stuff and it brings awareness to these
bands and then they do injustice for all
and injustice for all is like continuing
in a trajectory that makes sense from
kilomole to master of puppets it's
getting heavier harder harsher it's sort
of like let's see what trash metal can
actually do
unfortunately it was mixed badly you
know
um but it represented sort of the the
end point you could say of a musical
development the black album is like
swinging way over to the other side
you know it doesn't make sense as
something coming on the heels of
injustice for all whereas if oh
i'd say if they
if they'd had just those first three
albums and then the black element would
be less of an
there'd still be a like uh whoa what's
going on here kind of moment but i think
it wouldn't have been as in congress
you know with a lot of the students i
see the black album is kind of i mean a
lot of them weren't born yet but
yeah
the blackout mean all the riffs the
black album like you know
enter sandman is the yeah but like you
know being able to play the master of
puppets riff was really cool when i was
young
yeah play it you know
well i mean i think the song that uh
probably got the most imitation was fade
to black oh god yeah i mean that was the
first huge one i remember everybody was
doing the talent show
if they could they tried yeah
yeah
yeah because i mean we talked about that
it's in a certain way it's a power
ballad you know lots of people were
were uh
getting into it it's it's about you know
um
alienation and depression and stuff like
that yeah but it has the dynamics of the
power ballad
yeah i mean you know and there's more to
be said
um
you get like a power ball like nothing
else matters from the black album
and you know i remember seeing the video
talk about talk about ethos i just saw
you know uh they had
um what's his name uh jason newstead had
a ponytail glasses and he was reading
music in the studio and i said this is
like whoever set this up is
not metal and he doesn't read you know
it's like they're not yeah yeah we need
to believe that metallica sits there and
you know somebody's written the music
out for them to read to do this stuff
and i remember being disappointed at
that visual that they were trying to
come off as like sophisticated musicians
you know and there was the black it was
a black and white video too right it was
like okay yeah yeah i think that's right
yeah and i remember going what and just
being completely like i can't and then
but you know all the people that hated
metallica
really liked that album right yeah
that's i think that's why it was so
polarizing they managed to capture a
vast audience share that they'd missed
before
by
basically giving the finger to their
hardcore
uh supporters who'd been with them
through the entire chain and not to not
not
not to go somewhere totally different
but this is a
a really interesting point about
you know they had to sit and decide you
know um well i don't know but you know
for them to
you're almost contemptuous to your fans
then right like thanks for getting us to
this point where we get a
big money album yeah you know and then
now we're just gonna like you know
really cash in and and
you know have somebody come in and
uh
we'll cater to the people you won't that
bullied you
right
so i mean you know we always talk about
heavy metal as
you know you know we were the loners but
metal understood us in the outcast yeah
yeah they were the outcasts and all of a
sudden they're catering to the people
that bullied us and there's a there's a
there was something broken there as far
as like they wanted to be popular i mean
in our minds right yeah you know uh and
i think we should definitely do a show
specifically about case studies like
this um i mean you and i have talked
about this a lot is there some sort of
like
contract between
you know
the musicians and the fans no there's no
explicit contract but there's definitely
a whole set of expectations mark has a
little clip here should they have
changed their name from metallica to
raqqa
yeah i mean or or you know um
hard rock ensemble or something like
that
um
but that's interesting you know
but if we talk about original
members let's say that
kirk hammett and james hetfield weren't
part of the black album but you know a
new metallica
and then that album came out i think we
would be furious that somebody came in
and ruined it oh yeah yeah i mean
there'd be a different
you know and then you know but at least
we can accept that these softer versions
you know they can say they're the first
of the black album we want to say that
these people are the first of the you
know
kill them all era or the
you know um
yeah
so but you know the original members i
guess they you know
yeah
because we could do original members by
era right
like you know uh there's some bands i
mean is it useful to use original in
that case is the question that we're
going to
have to get to you know you're right so
in other words the well i mean
something to point out that that person
uh or those people were part of this era
right right
so you know we you can see that there's
a lot of problems with this
very strict sense of original right
because it leaves out some really key
players in these these major bands
um there's a couple other problems that
come up as well like bands that split up
and then reformed with just a few
members so the scorpions is a great
example of this the original scorpions
did have um
rudolf scheckner but a bunch of other
people and then it breaks up he joins
another band uh which klaus mina is in
and then um they're like well
let's use the scorpion's name
but it's really a refounded scorpions
band right it's not the original
original it's the new original
scorpions
and
um
you know iron maiden
at one point steve harris actually
disbanded iron maiden so that he could
reform it and get get rid of all these
people that he thought were kind of like
not very effective
yeah
judas priest did that
judas priest broke up and then reformed
so you could say well al atkins was the
original singer
yes of the
first judas priest not of the judas
priests that we actually recognize and
know
um well that's a good point that's well
said
yeah you know well i guess you know with
the scorpions too there's the
you know the the the um
you know like the blackout era and then
the 70s with uli john roth and the music
is very different
um
yeah although there is continuity
because you know same singer um more or
less same drummer and bassist in in much
of that time uh real schechner is still
writing all the songs
you know and there's this thing about
like bands that split up and reformed it
made me think this isn't quite like that
but what should we make of richie
blackmore
effectively taking ronnie james dio's
band elf
bringing them in
making rainbow and then saying i'm just
keeping ronnie james deal the rest of
you are fired
are they original members
you know these elf guys um oh
interesting not really right because
richie blackmore is running the show um
but it's kind of like reforming a band
isn't it
yeah i i guess yeah it's uh
it's a blunt way to do it
yeah well nobody ever claimed that
richie blackmore was a wonderful moral
person so
so let's let's talk about another
way of thinking about originality
another definition we could use is if
you played on the first album you're an
original member
and not an ep an actual
right lp
i mean this is maybe we should debate
this you know should an lp be the
criteria or could an ep or even a demo
count i don't know what do you think
scott
like iron maiden the sound house tapes
um oh or does it have to be iron maiden
the album i mean i just you know if
if the ep
turned to be classic or the ep
you know
had hits on it
yeah back then or well i don't i don't
let's not use the word hits because
uh but like you know let's say it did
really well with fans and fans hold it
in high regard yeah maybe but if the ep
was kind of like this is the budget we
have you're gonna make this and then you
can chop it around
okay it depends on the purpose of what
the ep was if it was a budget thing if
it was a so you could have enough
some material to sell at your shows if
like i think you know it goes down to
you know
was the ep kind of self produced and
self put out or and then you signed with
capital or what or whoever okay and then
you know the
you know and you're actually inking
something like um but yeah i would say
what you know
you brought up something earlier it's
like well you know is it kind of up to
the fan like if the fans
you know if the first album was a flop
and nobody had it nobody owns it
but the second one with the new people
and then the second third fourth fifth
sixth seventh album
are those the people that we want to see
in a reunion but we want to see the the
the band that
yeah
that's that's really interesting because
a lot of the first albums are kind of
like
we're trying something out maybe some of
this is gonna work some of this isn't
gonna work
um the band might have a lot less
control over the producing like you
think about rock-a-rolla
and judas priest being disappointed with
the production on it you know
um and rock-a-roll it's it's a good
album it's not like the number one judas
priest album ever it's not like they you
know
established themselves and they never
measured up to it after that i mean you
could say that rock and roll is perhaps
it might even be in the bottom half of
judah's priest albums i think for a lot
of fans
whereas you know sad wings of destiny
sin after sin you know they're
definitely
right moving up
um
deep purple is a great example for this
right so the the mark one lineup does
actually three albums together
before they bring in ian gillen as the
singer and roger glover as the bassist
and those first three albums they're
okay but they're not they're not the
deep purple that we think of deep purple
mark ii so first album doesn't really
work for them that well
um
quiet riot okay so we've got those first
two only in japan
sarzo is actually credited on the second
album even though he didn't play on it
it was kelly garney
oh and that might have been because he
was touring and it might have been
because dubrow was by that time just
finished with kelly garney
well interesting yeah i mean by that
well by that time
well that would have been 81.82 he was
kind of sarge was kind of bouncing
around right
yeah you know i think so yeah
yeah
um iron maiden uh the very first album
dennis stratton is uh
a guitarist who's who's there instead of
adrian smith as well you know now
recognized as a really central member of
the band paul diano of course is is the
singer on that first album and the
second album and and the ep made in
japan which seems to be for again total
digression like almost impossible to
find these days i had it as a kid made
in japan but
i had the tape yeah
yeah you're right i
i i should look to see because i've
wondered about that when that was put
out of print
right right is that why and why i mean
anything can be kept in print right
pretty easily
so
uh was that god that was um was that the
rainbow show is that the because it came
out in the dvd set the iron maiden the
early years it only had five tracks on
it um it was it was a an ep that was
like the size of uh
nlp
had some nice you know like art of the
concert and stuff like that but i don't
remember too well because i haven't i
haven't had my hands on it for a long
time i think yeah because the the live
at the rainbow
the video of that show came out on the
box the dvd box years ago
um
and
i mean
if it's not the same show it's in the
same year yeah but uh it's it
well no it made it wouldn't be at the
right i mean this was this was recorded
in in japan
made in japan yeah that's right i mean
playing off of the deep purple
right thing as well but you know if you
think about um
some of these other bands would this
original member thing work so with judas
priest it kind of works except for
drummers are going to change right but
nobody i mean
this is going to sound awful but
nobody really goes to judah's priest and
they're like oh man i've got to see who
the drummer is
it's you know it's ian hill and
rob halford and the guitarists you know
well here's an interesting question take
a band like kiss okay who could have the
original members back yeah
now what is this for a while i mean
they're getting pretty old
oh yeah yeah yeah of course but you know
there's been the big fight you know the
fans want to see ace defeat no but and
then ace likes to stir it up but they're
like well he's not reliable
yeah
but
so
but
um
do gina and paul do a really do they do
a great job
of getting fans to go along with
the their the
their the real kiss those two gene and
paul and that you know all the like
tommy thayer is like
this is the band i mean they still would
sell out anything so people are not
buying tickets i mean i don't see
i don't see gene
simmons and paul stanley ever denying
that peter chris and ace really are
original members i think it's more along
the lines of like listen this this band
just doesn't work well together
um when we bring them in we've tried it
out a couple times we're not we're not
reaching out to those guys you know you
know they get it came to a head at the
rock and roll hall of fame yeah yeah
right and that was just
um
you know that
this is an issue we should talk about
with that because um
there's a bunch of bands where there was
debate whether you're gonna use the
person
like original members are you right the
people that were on that album
perform
yeah
and kiss comes to mind is you know
uh and i didn't
i don't remember quotes from that
interview i didn't come equipped with
that but it's if you think about it
i would think that whoever was in the
band
for the career that got you into the
hall of fame
should be in there right so it's
original
um
yeah yeah
but uh i think you know but then
i think genius
it's tough to say though in terms of
like
i mean the hall of fame rock and roll
hall of fame is is itself a hot mess
anyway because they handle things and
what they're willing to call rock and
roll but put all that aside
who
has agency who is responsible for a band
having the success that they do i mean
you could say well the original
members or the people on the first album
like set the mold and then it's moving
forward from there
but i i think in you know especially if
we're talking about bands that have a
40-year or even now 50-year
tail
we might say well
you know i mean kiss was doing okay
really great in the 70s and then in the
early 80s they were kind of foundering a
bit there's some some good
albums and some some good songs but they
they kind of didn't really know what
their mark is and then now
with tommy thayer
and eric carr as really really long-term
um
stand-ins you know i mean they wear the
makeup
um
and they they have the persona eric
singer right yeah yeah i'm sorry yeah
eric singer um
eric carr he was he was a guitarist
right no no he was a drummer okay passed
away though that's right yeah so so you
know from like the late 80s early 90s
onward i guess you could say these these
are guys who are contributing to kiss
being a success
you know yeah but
but to have but to not have everybody
there yeah especially you know there's a
70s kiss and the 80s kiss i mean that's
i mean that's like a hard line draw with
them coincidence right right yeah
we're looking up was what 1980 81
that sounds about right i think 81 yeah
yeah i remember seeing it at cal door
you know i remember
i remember hearing it played on a
boombox because i think it was on the
masters of metal cassettes
right and we'd go on these camping trips
and the older kids would um both you
know like steal liquor from their dad's
liquor cabinets and have like a boom box
with the latest metal stuff and we'd
wander around listening to it you know
sipping uh whatever crappy stuff brandy
slogen you name it
that they were able to get their hands
on
um
[Music]
mark says uh some of what it means for a
band to be who it is is due to the
activity its members sometimes it yeah
this is massive it seems to come down to
such contingent factors to luck what
what the ancients called fortuna you
know uh being in the right place at the
right time you know and you could you
could say this about quiet riot they
really and this is where kevin de brown
like you know this is where he went off
the rails because you had you had quiet
riot
and van halen and a few other bands as
well in the 70s in l.a
like
you know everyone is telling them heavy
metal is dead nobody wants to listen to
that crap anymore uh it's punk it's
disco it's it's soft rock and they they
kept going ahead with it
playing in the in the clubs and stuff
like that
and why did van halen succeed and quiet
riot at first did not succeed
at the same time that like you know um
you've got the early configurations of
wasp with um sister and circus circus
you've got mickey rat
and all that why why are some bands
succeeding and other bands not um well i
mean somebody like ozzy osbourne coming
in and saying i like that guitarist i
want him for my band and poaching him
away
you know or the record company screwing
you around and saying yeah we're going
to release a record it's just only going
to be there in japan not in the united
states you know right so kevin dupre
kevin dubrow for people who don't know
this became very very bitter
and he would in the 1980s when when
quiet riot was at the height of their
success
having released mental health and then
the
condition critical which has some
stuff on it he would get up on stage and
then he'd be like bad mouthing
all these other la bands including van
halen motley crew rat
wasp you know some of the bands that
were also big at the time and it turned
a lot of people off including his own
band members
yeah that's um
that's interesting and i wonder
if later on he ever like looked back and
said i was young and stupid
that's a good that's something we should
dig into yeah because i'm wondering if
we don't want to assume that well maybe
i mean maybe he still feels that way
maybe in an interview we could find
something
more recent where he says yeah yeah you
know no i we we should have been huge
those bands you know did it uh
um well but mark is right a lot of it i
mean you can be a hard hard worker
all the time and maybe things just don't
don't work out you know as we always say
you know the the music business is not a
meritocracy at all
in fact these days when stuff's on the
radio it's paid to be there or it's paid
to be in the spotify i mean you know
it's you it's going to be it's it's
already a hit even if you're not
listening to it yeah
so
you know back then of course there was
money behind albums and promotions but
yeah we had yeah paola but we had to
like end up buying a ticket to the show
that's true yeah and so you
well and you and you could you could do
things like go around and pass out the
flyers right that was something bands
were doing you could drum up the
business um that's part of why
you know van halen bringing in david lee
roth although they didn't get along with
him at first brilliant move because that
guy could like sell anything yeah and uh
he wouldn't take no for an answer just
keep plowing ahead
when other people would get discouraged
but that's all it's always funny when
they interview people
even even people in movies that act and
stuff it's uh
you know well how did you do it well it
was x y and z and every time i hear that
it's like well it probably wasn't
yeah you probably have no idea you know
well it was xyz and the rest of the
alphabet behind him
i love that
well you know it's like i said you know
i said i i always think it's like you
know it could be that 10 years ago you
took a left turn instead of a right turn
at a stop sign and you were in an
accident you met someone and you know
maybe that there was like
steps from that that led to it that you
you don't even know i mean it's it's
or sometimes it's just i don't know like
it's unexplainable but that's it's it's
very true that well and and to bring
this in a philosophical way this is
something that an ancient philosophy
they were really concerned with they
called this fortune right to what degree
does our happiness and success depend on
ourselves or on
fortune this wheel that turns you know
and
sometimes you're on the good end of it
and sometimes you're on the bottom end
of it um
and i think there's there's so many
bands that we could talk about i mean we
could actually do like a whole show on
like
bands that should have succeeded but
what the hell happened to them like a
prime example
the band riot um if you you know
i really strongly suggest that at least
for the first three albums um rock city
narita and i'm blanking on the name of
the third album um someone that's got
swords and tequila on it those are
really really awesome and riot was
actually getting written up in karang as
being like an honorary part of the new
wave of british heavy metal even though
they're a new york band right what
screwed them quiet riot
quiet riot coming out being big people
mixed the two of them up
and
that was that was it from there you know
that and their lead singer leaving
to become
you know like he moved down to florida
and became like a contractor or
something like that left the music
business all together those sort of
things i mean how do you predict those
you can't and you can have all of your
proverbial ducks in a row and then
something like that comes along and
just screws you over or again you know
cliff cliff burton dying
uh when a tour bus flips over on tour i
mean who would have predicted that or
randy rhodes you know dying in a plane
crash right so yeah
but let's come back oh go ahead no no
that was it i was exactly yeah i agree
so let's talk about this first album
criteria and we we can maybe push that
out of the way because here think about
the scorpions right
if we take the first album then
uh michael schenckner is
you know one of the original members not
ulivan roth not matthias jobs not
francis bucholtz not herman rarebell um
so you know those are some pretty
important admissions however ufo would
not include michael schechner the
guitarist who's like associated with
their great success
uh included instead it would be mick
bolt you know on on guitar so you know
we have to think about um
what happens as bands move out of their
debut
and become more successful develop
musically as performers start having
personality disagreements and things and
eventually attain like a more stable
lineup
um you know so iron maiden will be a
great example for that
and to go back to something that we were
talking about a little bit earlier i
don't think that we can extend the
criterion for original
founding per se into the lineup for the
second third and fourth or you know
whatever album because we're starting to
lose the meaning so maybe we need a
different term maybe we have to talk
about essential members classic lineup
like like rudy sarzo was doing
i'm a a founding member of the metal
health lineup
you know
maybe that's what makes sense to do i i
agree
yeah um a founding member and then he he
names well essentially you could name an
era
yeah
well and so now this goes to if we want
to try to figure out criteria for this
what would be a classic lineup um
i'm gonna throw a bunch of things out
there and then then you use scott and
mark and anybody else think about what
else
would need to be there it's got to be
stable right so you can't have people
coming in going out and have a classic
lineup they've got to be able to record
and tour successfully
i think it's also important that they
produce the catalog that in its
in time is going to be solid songs
become staple songs and then
deep cuts so like what you were talking
about earlier scott you know setting
setting what people going to concerts
are going to want to hear in in the set
list like if you go to a uriah heap
concert and you don't hear gypsy
or um
a bird of prey maybe as a substitute for
gypsy
something's wrong right if you go to uh
a kiss concert and they don't play
anything from the early stuff like deuce
or
right uh rock and roll all night yeah i
mean you'd be like what's what's going
on here you know
yeah that's one way they could get eight
encores hold out with that
so i mean what do you think else has to
go into a stable lineup
uh it's got it or in a classic item it's
got to be stable they got to be
recording and touring successfully they
got to be producing the stuff that's
going to be like core catalog
chord discography i mean
what you say
about the the the fan recognition thing
is a tough one because
maybe you can
help with a philosoph philosophical
thing here
let's take a band we always always
i love the band but i always use them as
a bad example def leppard
now sometimes yeah yeah yeah
now something's wrong if we don't hear
eight songs from hysteria
not us but if you and i
go to a def leppard show we want to hear
on through the night and and yeah you
know and maybe the new well but like you
want to hear high and dry we want to
hear maybe you know in pyromania yeah
and maybe one so who's the real fan i
mean you know it's like
if if they went and didn't play anything
off of
um hysteria could i mean that's a dare
could you could if i said
you can't play anything from hysteria
what are you gonna do if would that make
them nervous
you know
there's another factor here
they're used to doing that they're used
to playing hysteria as like the core of
their their repertoire and
they would have to actually probably do
a lot of practicing for a tour that was
going to de-emphasize hysteria they
would have to like bring out some of
these some of these songs they haven't
played for years and years and years
and um get good at playing them
and well it's another thing because we
consider phil collins to be an original
member but he's not he wasn't on high
and dry he wasn't on
he he's not in the classics he was only
on one track on um
pyromania
oh is that true yeah and he's interested
in his first album so i understand why
yeah yeah
why he loves that album because that was
the sound that he brought to the band
yeah and it's it's great it's just that
was an album that when it came out i was
i was really not happy yeah me either i
was i i was very disappointed with it
um i've also seen their recent set lists
and that's exactly what they're still
doing is mostly songs from
uh hysteria a few from pyromania almost
nothing from the earlier period and then
a few songs off of the new album and
that's it now mark has some good good
questions what about the level of
success album sales awards one
popularity so awards one
i don't i think that's gonna like wind
up being something that happens decades
down the line like getting inducted into
rock and roll hall of fame or stuff like
that
album sales that's that's an interesting
one because some of these bands i
remember reading when we were doing the
research on the the rob halford and kk
downing thing
reading their books and they never had
like the level of album sales that say
iron maiden had let alone metallica had
you know yeah um
well so so i i that's that's a tough one
um
i think
but see as metal heads
we don't put stock in any that we don't
put like you know we didn't hear iron
maiden on the radio we didn't hear
we didn't really see them on mtv much it
wasn't like
as metal heads
we kind of agreed in an underground way
whereas if you take poppy
and it's like well you know so and so
they're you know their best-selling
album was this you know the you know
that might speak to the the band about
what they should play like i'm sure
hysterias sold the most right right
totally yeah so but like you know
they're kind of pyromania is probably
the second all right i got everyone had
power mania when it came you had to have
it um but they you know they don't they
they play a few from that that you know
so here's here's mark is following up
with this and says aren't these part of
what makes mental health so definitive
for quiet riot and i think yes that's
that's what put quiet riot in front of
everybody right so they did get radio
airplay they did get mtv videos but i
think at that time they had indeed
managed to attain
a stable lineup one that did have
personality conflicts but which could
could manage those tensions for a while
until they had fired to brow you know
and they were producing
i mean
like a condition critical like i
mentioned it's great great album but
um i don't think there's as much in
their repertoire from
that as there is from mental health you
know
um
and if you if you think you know what
are the other great quiet riot albums
does anything come to mind nothing those
are the two albums yeah well you know
it's a great point mark because
now we're starting to see um
i think bands like them and twisted
sister they got on the radio at the same
time yeah yeah and that's not um
it's not
it's not common for metal bands but look
what their vocal content was the 80s was
about standing up to the parents that
wanted to think and
iron maiden wasn't singing about that
so you know we're not going to take it
you know the video you know throwing the
the teacher into the basketball hoop
yeah so you know
and of course the movie footloose
breakfast club um all these movies about
uh rebellion rebellion and um
swiss's sister and and uh quite riot
were great
they really sang about the rebellion
thing and i maybe that's why it made it
on the mainstream
wasn't singing about like standing up to
the parents or
you know
yeah on perfect strangers no
i mean they were more of a like
you know an older person's band that was
talking about like
what it was like being rockers in the
70s or you know
you know
one too many wasted sunsets i mean
wonderful things there's not a bad song
on that album no i love that um
yeah different very different content so
if we go to this classic lineup thing
right
um van halen
easy right it's the
the the four um
uh the two van halen brothers michael
anthony david lee roth that's the
classic lineup
um
metallica
with cliff burton um
for judas priest it's the the four and
then whatever drummer they have
for iron maiden now here's where it gets
interesting this is where i really want
to get scott's take on this
so bruce dickinson very clearly becomes
part of the classic lineup replacing
paul diano and he can take the pauldiano
era songs and make him his own you know
running free
off of live after death probably better
than um diano singing it on iron maiden
um adrian smith you know by the second
album he's already there he and dave
murray like
gelled together right in in a way that i
think some of the other two guitar
people
haven't done you know like we find out
you know later on that glenn tipton and
k.k downing were never really seeing eye
to eye in judas priest um now
what about
so you're willing to say that those are
classic lineup players right bruce
dickinson and adrian smith
i mean yeah although i will say
um
the first lineup with diano and um
dennis stratton
no not dennis stratton the drummer come
on scott oh clive burr
i
i i love his drumming infinitely more
than i mean that was a
the rhythm section was so great on those
two diano albums well and uh a number of
the beast
number of the beast you're right yeah
and that's that's like
um he wasn't such a big personality but
you know so it's it's
i love both of them but you know one's
more of a punk band and one was a
completely different thing so
that's what i was going to ask you about
is nico mcbrain
a classic
iron maiden classic lineup of iron
maiden member i mean he's been with them
for a million albums
yeah and that's that's part of your
criteria yeah and and it includes peace
of mind and power slaves
of the albums yeah what do you
should he be considered
at this point in time a
member of the classic lineup of iron
maiden um
[Music]
that's a really good one because they're
well i mean
clive passed away so you know we can't
talk about well should clive come back
in the band right right um no because
the con the contribution to all the
albums that were so different than the
first couple you know like once dionne
i mean even number the beast was pretty
different
you know and we had the the same drummer
so i i think the big change is
i think we all respect the the diana's
stuff but we knew that he couldn't keep
that going we knew we went off
um
and apparently he was a raging a-hole
too um again coming from the uh the
judas free stuff right judas priest was
an established band by the time that
iron maiden is playing with them and the
the one guy who's starting crap besides
their manager
is paul diana he's like talking trash
you know after they've only got one
album out he's talking trash to the
members of judah's priest you know i
think to the point where they're like
we're going to beat the crap out of this
guy you know
that's oh you know i didn't i didn't
realize that i just knew
i think he well he got fired for just
using too much right he was unreliable
well he got fired for that he got fired
for
being kind of a loose cannon but they
all i mean it was also clear that they
thought in order to move to the next
level we need a better singer we need
somebody who can project out to these
these uh massive audiences
that they weren't going to grow with
diana they i mean you know they would
have
dickenson was
he he is
far more versatile
you know that's an interesting point
that you've got there about growing
right because maybe there's a tension to
between like having
a classic really well-defined sound
that's reliable
but also
um being able to grow
i mean you look at iron maiden for those
those early albums so
the first one is pretty is pretty raw
killers is definitely better than iron
maiden yeah then number of the beast is
like even better than that peace of mind
this is where we get people get into the
disputes i think peace of mind is is
marginally better than number of the
beast and yeah
is kind of holding holding constant but
each one is a different kind of sound a
different kind of album you know and you
have to remember that the mindset back
then
was you were in it for the long long
haul because record companies would
invest
right in six albums before you made it
now it's um
you know
now you're you know
you make your statement out because
you'll be gone tomorrow and yeah yeah
you know there was a different mindset
back then so it makes sense that you
know um if steve harris is coming up
with the more progressive kind of stuff
that he's thinking of
um this is an interesting side point
from from mark um
he's read that diana was later diagnosed
with bipolar disorder i think
undiagnosed mental health concerns in
musicians this is an interesting topic
to consider
obviously ties in with drug abuse but
that's another one of those factors of
fate yeah and
i mean
a lot of these things were just not
being recognized
at the time you were just an unreliable
a-hole you know um
well that's a great point because you
see all the guys in deep purple talking
about tommy bolin who was a guitarist oh
yeah and he died a tragic story yeah and
um and they said you know look you know
in his defense back then we didn't know
you know back then it was all fun and
games and we didn't really you know
somebody odd and you know and then we'd
move on then we'd move on it was just
you know um
uh
i guess it wasn't like you know
addiction and all the stuff wasn't as
recognized at the time or it was you
know it was part of the i mean look like
it was romanticized it was romanticized
because look they were deep purple if
you go to the early 70s
um
you know
they had nothing to look back on i mean
beatles 64 ed sullivan yeah first rock
band
jimi hendrix and jimi hendrix and the 27
club you know all three of them uh
janice joplin hendricks yeah
uh
jim morrison
and
yeah but then you come up with these
bands and it was kind of like you hear
these stories that
the one
um where tommy bull and they fly out to
do
taste the band
and he went out got trashed and met
these women in germany and brought him
back and then saw these pills on the
board just took them all
and then after he took him he goes oh
what was that and they go well you're
not going to die but you're going to
sleep for a long time because they're
all sleeping pills they were supposed to
take to get rest before recording wow
and so um
yeah i guess that but it's a good point
about the mark that you make about uh
about diagnosing uh mental illness
yeah it's i don't know and managing it
you know i mean
you can you can still be successful but
but it requires
attentiveness and like laying down
limits
which i don't think a lot of people were
very
interested in or good at back then you
know
that's yeah and um
that's that's that is a great point
because like i said you know you have to
realize the mindset
is you know we need somebody more
versatile we can't stay in this pumpkin
i'm starting to you know like uh
steve harris is starting to write more
epic songs that aren't three minute punk
songs he's starting to write
yeah longer tunes that involve more of a
less of a movement and yeah yeah
and um
and you know i think that was a wise
choice but you know
that wouldn't make a lot of sense to a
lot of people these days if they wanted
to kind of
be torn it's just kind of like what's
going to get us now it's going to give
us more likes and more follows or
whatever yeah where it's not um
we're considering these things shifting
back to like the uh classic lineup idea
and talking about essential members and
things like that
i wonder if we can't at least with some
bands talk about
multiple eras and i think this is
something you were getting at earlier
scott so like black sabbath is one that
i have in mind
there is really two classic black
sabbath eras there's the
one with ozzy osbourne that runs
basically
seven years or so
it's got
bill ward on drums for all of that
actually singing one of the songs on on
one of the the last albums uh never say
die because ozzie wouldn't sing it
and then um you've got the dio era right
which is it's pretty short you know um
mob rules um
uh
heaven and hell and then there's there's
a reunion later on that dehumanizer
um and ozzie brings in cozy powell on
drums right so ward is replaced but you
do have continuity because it's yomi and
butler in those and i think we we could
talk about those as being two classic
lineups because they reform later right
they're they're willing to do that
um
ian gillen just there for one album
definitely not like a classic essential
member although i said it's a great
album i think um born again
um glenn hughes um also there tony
martin who doesn't get enough love i
think um but but it's really only the
aussie and the dio era that could be
considered the classic
lineup i think um for deb for cl for for
quiet riot it's definitely the mental
health era yeah um for tank
you know
formed by algae ward originally he's got
these two guys the brobz brothers
and so the early tank is a trio and then
for honor and blood he brings in two
guitars cliff evans and mick tucker
which is the classic lineup um i kind of
think they both are in part because
there's currently two tanks out there lg
ward by himself in his studio recording
and then the tank that's currently
touring is cliff evans mctucker and
whoever else they get to uh
to be with them
um and they they you know they play the
classic era stuff honor was on it or
the honor was i think the fourth album
for tank so it's it's pretty early in
their career you know
another thing i think we want to
consider is how do people become
essential members of the band
so you know like bruce dickinson becomes
an essential member because he auditions
and starts singing on albums and does
the old stuff but does a lot of the new
stuff yep um the scorpions francis
bucholtz hermann rarebell i would say
that they are essential members of the
band at least the scorpions that we know
right and love
because they're they're playing on all
the essential 70s and 80s stuff
girls school there's kind of a cool
story with that so
the current guitarist
is jackie chambers and she's been the
guitarist for a while
and
she was not just replacing
kelly johnson she was trained and
mentored by
kelly johnson
and
chris
bonacci the other person who'd been a
lead guitarist so that she could replace
them
in the band because kelly johnson was
dying of cancer
she had um six years of therapy and
treatment
and um
she actually shared a flat in london
with kelly johnson chambers and and
johnson and so this is like a deliberate
decision we need somebody so imagine
that like um
steve harris and iron maiden
um found out that he's he's got cancer
and he's gonna die in five years and he
wants the band to go on and then he
finds a
you know maybe 20-something bassist
who's kind of like him in certain
respects and he's like
i'm gonna make you into not a clone of
me but somebody who clearly represents
my
influence that's essentially what girls
school did
you know
that's you know i can't imagine
i mean i would i would
i would say for steve harris that's a
tough one because you there's only one
steve harris you can't
no you could you could
you know um
yeah well i find that interesting with
the girls school because i had heard you
tell me that before and i'm thinking
did this person not play guitar very
much no no she played guitar um but she
just was not at the level
that
girl school wanted her
and so they were like we're investing in
you gotcha yeah because like you know
basically the records would tell you how
to play but
um if she wasn't on the level to pick
out what was actually going on on the
records
um then that make that would make sense
you know there's that and she's also got
to be
um
one of the front people in concert right
that's true so there's other aspects i
guess you could say of the performance
that are
that are required um here's another
question for you going back to kiss
um
has tommy thayer maybe he's not a
classic kiss era person right
has he become an essential member of the
band
you know tommy there is yeah
you know he's the only one that um
he's the one that comes closest to ace
right bruce keller
didn't have a he wasn't there to imitate
ace although he did some of the soul of
the classic solos yeah we didn't mind if
he didn't sound like gates because it
was the
the 80s era of it right um yeah
uh vinnie vincent read you know he was
the he didn't sound anything he was a
totally different thing yeah totally
different thing so tommy there is
um
you know he wears the he he wears the
ace makeup right right yeah and like you
know for everybody else they had their
own makeup so he he's he's essentially
you know
so can you be essential if you're
playing somebody yeah i know i you know
no because you could find somebody else
to play ace
ace is the essential if you're imitating
ace if you're trying to be ace
eight you're trying to imitate the
essential
yeah
i i think so this goes back to the issue
of mimesis that we were exploring in
previous episodes
and tribute bands and things like that
yeah
i mean right i mean the point of it he's
essentially doing a tribute part in the
real band it's like whereas like bruce
bruce kulick was doing himself in the
band he was he was bringing his thing to
the table and he was contributing to
kiss in his way of how he sounded how he
looked
um
and there was a reason why they got him
in the bands but he was like nothing he
didn't look anything like this he didn't
sound anything like ace and uh now to
have it's like well we can't have the
real ace will you suit up and you know
wear the ace makeup and you know play
the les pauls and like play that yeah
because he's the only one that did
everybody like
what's his name was a big well
i'm sure they all played les pauls
sometimes but uh
what's his name was a culick was a big
kramer guy in that all on those records
he's playing kramer guitars the you know
the hockey stick headstock ones
the 80s version
yeah
well before we wrap up let me let me
throw one more thing on the table what
about bands
that
have been around for a long time and
they've got a later lasting lineup the
one that's currently touring and it's
been around for like decades
would you say that some of those members
are
now like absolutely essential members so
i'm thinking for example of uriah heap
where you got mick box on guitar who's a
great guitarist and he's you know great
band leader
and then you've got um
like bernie shaw
on on vocals and phil lansin on on
keyboards and they have been with the
band since the 80s i mean uriah heap
gets going in the late 60s
uh
starts putting out albums in the 70s and
you know interesting repertoire some of
the original members are dead um
lee curse lake was the longest drummer
trevor boulder was the longest bassist
but russell gilbrook has been on drums
since 2007 so you know
15 years dave rimmer on base a little
bit more recently 2013 but it's close to
a decade
are these essential members i mean i
might say dave rimmer on base maybe not
but bernie shaw as the singer he's not
an original singer of uriah he but he
has been with them since the 80s so
i don't know what do you think yeah i
mean um
you know
what we have to like include in the
variables is
you know all these bands say we didn't
know this was going to last more than
five years and now yeah or 40 45 years
later
you know um
uh people retire um so i guess the
question is do we want the bands to go
on or not so is it
like with your eye heap oh wait yeah
mark's got some great follow-ups that
feed into that
would you rather watch a 70-something
year old version of the original band
struggling on stage or a younger more
energetic tribute version who can
perform the songs closer to their
original technical
demands
well interesting um
and this is going to become more and
more of a pressing problem as these
bands that are currently like you know
members are in their 60s early 70s as
they move into their 80s
you know like say judas priest for
example right or or kiss or iron maiden
who's a little bit younger than right on
the whole than judas priest or kiss but
i mean
this is going to become a pressing
problem in the cur current decades
there's going to there's going to come a
time
when um adrian smith and dave murray
can't do their solos or
the stuff the way they're used to we
talked about this with with certain
singers right um who
basically can't like not only can they
not hit the notes they also have lost
the phrasing you know this is going to
happen to everybody sooner or later so
so i might rather watch i would rather
well so like i saw queen
and what's he is he is brian may in his
70s
yeah he has to be and there's like him
just hitting a chord is is is a
experience and he and he's he sounds
wonderful you know i would say there's a
time to hang it up
yeah you know um and you know i don't
want to see what's like the whole thing
we talked about like you know
you know kiss is going to license it so
there's an official kiss tribute band i
don't want to see that i don't want to
say that because you know um that's not
you know and and sadly it's like i don't
know how it is around the rest of the
country but here
all the the old theaters that have like
you know have
dance and theater and music
they're completely booked with tribute
bands oh really no it's not like that
here in the midwest um that's
interesting to hear about the
boston area yeah so tr so tribute bins
and i i say to these people like just
just close this theater you're not this
there's no art going on here no this is
what pays the bills
and then you know they you know that's
you know i guess the public has spoken
that you know they won't pay i've i've
done some shows in the theaters and
50 tickets out of 2000 but then they get
like a
you know a pretty bad tom petty tribute
band but people just want to sing along
and i
i don't understand it you know i don't
understand it and it's i don't know if
it's a cultural thing that's going on
right now so i definitely would rather
than see the 70 year old or you know
it's time to call it a day
you know and you know that's what it is
and we have records we have the live
dvds for that era or the and you know it
it can't go on you know people
people eventually die so i wouldn't like
to see um
because nobody's gonna sound just like
brian may even if they get somebody
that's got the close thing it's not
brian may
and there's other there's other great
unique artists but those are what the
records are for
you know they they capture those moments
in time and we can put them on our
turntable so to speak anytime we want
yeah yeah and you know
it's kind of like we're not going to
hear debussy perform his pieces on piano
ever again
but um yeah but like that's a different
thing because you know there was a
separation between the composer and the
performer in that genre so well maybe
like you know somebody who would be
comparable would be eric saty right
because i think he did perform some of
his piano pieces right but you know he's
gone so
art and age of mechanical yeah i mean so
that's a reference to the title by uh
walter benjamin an essay that gets
brought up an awful lot ironically this
is the essay is from almost i think a
century ago
um
and and uh yeah i mean we're
i think that we're always
now like in our lifetime in an age of
mechanical reproduction but it doesn't
have to be
merely mechanical right can there still
be some soul to the music that you can
hear through the
the um
mass-produced copies you know that we
call an album yeah definitely
so there's always this tension um
in it but
these are there's a lot of great topics
here that we'll we'll probably have to
explore in uh future time so we you know
to sum it up we've got a couple
different versions of being original
none of which are particularly helpful
and it seems like more we have to talk
about like classic lineups yeah um
if we want if we're thinking about like
musical
ability and
producing something that's lasting
it's not you know i mean lonesome crow
is an interesting album
that's not who the scorpions really are
or even really were
um
[Music]
you know
now scott you're you brought up the
blackout era blackout absolutely central
album but i would say taken by forces
too you know yeah or in trance and then
love it for sting yes as a matter of
fact i'll close on something rather
controversial i'll say love at first
sting was really the last great
scorpion's album
ah well
savage amusement was for me was sort of
like def leppard's hysteria i get that
although the songs are fantastic on
savage amusement
i love the songs you know
um
but yeah i know i mean when i got it it
was it was weird because you know i went
you and i both went to bed to worldwide
live every night right that was like i
actually had something different i had
a 45 minute tape right because back then
everything was yeah like the 30 minute
tapes and the 45 minute tapes and the 30
minute tapes were not long enough to put
a full album on usually so you'd get
yourself you pay the extra money and i
had blackout on one side
and love that first sting on the other
and i had a i had a
boombox that had the special tape player
that when you got to the end of a tape
you would story yeah exactly and so it
would play both sides until i turned it
off
and there was something about the
scorpions compositions
in all that stuff even on the heavy
songs that i i just found they were sort
of like lullabies you know
i
i love those albums i love those albums
and yeah um i it's so funny savage
amusement fantastic songs i love the
songs on that album i know what you mean
the production was like
you know it's like it was kind of a
shock
um
it was kind of like that
so it was kind of like with led zeppelin
the um
i love houses of the holy
oh
mark um i'm sorry
i've seen it before but oh yeah yeah
in mine
houses of the holy yeah
amazing
left to a different topic another time
led zeppelin to me got better by the
album you know
a lot of people like no the first record
you know and i you know if i want to be
like a jerk uh heavy metal asmr nice
yeah
i mean actually that that's a great
observation that has a great
you know with a lot of these bands you
kind of should expect them to get better
at least maybe reach a peak or something
like that like you know think about
accept for example
um their first couple albums they're not
they're not bad there's actually some
real good songs on there but they're not
restless and wild or um
balls to the wall you know or metal
heart that's sort of the the
yeah
for the early accept i mean you could
talk about well what about their later
stuff like you know
stalingrad and all that with uh mark
ternillo as the the singer and people
like that hey yeah that there's
something to that but but the early
stuff there's definitely like a cresting
that goes up
very few bands come out with like their
absolutely best stuff on their first
album i would say uh yeah no i
i agree and you know well you know with
um
with led zeppelin i mean it got better
better physical graffiti is infinitely
better than zeppelin ii you know um i
love presents i like you know as led
zeppelin but
yeah i just you know they became
songwriters
the songs became great as first it was
just blues covers
yeah
i mean deep purple again is great
example of that those first three albums
there's some things that are kind of fun
on that but it's it's not mark 2d purple
which is like
you know really really solid something
we should pay attention to when john
bonham died led zeppelin died yeah like
you know that's an interesting thing i i
um like who are you gonna john bonham's
the greatest one of the greatest in
history and who are you gonna replace
john bonham with it wasn't just the fact
that you can't replace him it was also
the fact that robert plant um
was grieving
yeah and didn't want to continue on with
with the
the stuff yeah and i i'm glad so so
these these kind of random effects you
could say right that that occur
yeah i mean and jimmy page had a cool
soul um and so did robert and they
continued it just wasn't led zeppelin
which is fine
right
yeah and maybe you know i'll i'll say
this and then then we should probably
wrap up but i'd be interested to hear
your thoughts about it
maybe we shouldn't expect of bands that
they have to like keep producing album
after album after album if they if they
manage to produce
six really really good albums maybe
that's
you know
as much as one can expect you know
i mean there are some bands that have
consistently produced lots and lots of
great albums
but
six already is like astronomical as far
as achievement and you start to hear it
in a lot of the albums like you know
when we revisit it's like well this is
why did you bother doing this record the
fire's gone you know you just did it to
do it and you're not gonna play anything
from it and
you know where's where's the song
writing or where's the and um some of
them have been really good like i loved
last time the you know talk about the
uriah heat album i like a lot yeah you
know i thought they did a great job on
it and i don't think they phoned it in
but so many bands do and it's like don't
do that we we want to remember liking
you you know
yeah
mark says i think dropping one good
album that shifts the genre's landscape
into significant ways enough to qualify
yeah
or do you think that's more indicative
of a fortune i would say both um i mean
being able to shift a landscape really
is being in the right place at the right
time um
but
i think there are some albums like that
you know
for better for worse because hysteria is
one that you know
it changed
and you know
i don't you know these days i don't hate
the album i appreciate the album but i
will put high and dry on the turntable
first
yeah or
are uh
uh
on the night yeah yeah
yeah those are those are both great well
we should we should probably wrap up um
we're already going a little bit over
time here but great discussion and yeah
thanks for the questions and
i think we've kind of you know reached a
consensus on this topic rudy sarzo is
certainly has the right to call himself
an original member in the qualified
sense which probably is more important
than being
uh a strictly speaking original member
right the band and i think that that
applies to a lot of people you know
yeah no it's it's good it's good we got
into all the different examples
yeah
all right well we'll see you next time
awesome yeah
take care
you